JOHN HUNTON: Well, as far as I'm
concerned, the important
thing about five is that it's
not three, four, or six.
And three, four, or six are each
numbers that have really
special properties in relation
to tiling the plane--
so creating repeating
patterns of tiles.
So I brought some props.
And here they are squares.
These are the sort of squares
that we all put on our walls.
And the pattern is
very simple.
And anyone can carry on putting
down square tiles, and
the pattern repeats itself
on, and on, and on.
You don't need instructions
because
you know how it continues.
Now, suppose you want
something a bit
more exotic than that.
Let's say you wanted
triangle tiles.
Say your tiles were
triangles--
like that.
Well, you could put the next one
upside down, and the third
one back the same way.
And then you can continue, and
then you put the next row in.
And you can continue this
for as long as you want.
So that would carry on for as
long as you want, using the
same rule, again and again and
again, just so you know how to
put down the tiles--
one up, one down.
So that's gonna be the three.
So these are tiles with three
sides, three corners.
Our original squares had four
sides, four corners.
But maybe you want something
more exotic still, and you
want to use hexagonal tiles.
So I can use this
pattern again.
I'll just draw over it.
So there was a hexagon.
You see this red.
And I could have another
hexagon.
It would come in, and that
one, and my third
hexagon, and so.
And I can continue to put
hexagons down, as well.
This is what the bees know.
And all the bees have to know
is where to put the next
little cell of their
honeycomb.
So here's the question--
can we use 5-sided?
So the answer is,
no, we can't.
five sides, equal sides,
equal angles.
So I might put the next
one down here.
And now you begin to
see your problem.
Because the bit I'd have to
fill in around here is a
bigger angle than my pentagon
has at its angle.
I'd get something like that, and
there'd be this little bit
of extra space.
Now you see, it didn't happen
with the hexagons, because the
hexagons had just that little
bit extra angle.
And so they filled
in these gaps.
So here you'll have another.
And you get another gap.
Triangles, 3-sided figures,
squares, 4-sided figures, and
hexagons, 6-sided figures, are
all good for tiling your wall.
But five, pentagons--
they're no good.
Six is the last one
you can do.
As soon as you start getting
even bigger figures, again,
there with many sides, then the
angles become too shallow.
So that the next one would only
have a little bit-- if I
put in another polygon out here
to match that one there--
I'd end up with only a little
sliver, and I'd never get
something in there.
So you can't do 7-sided
figures,
8-sided, 9-sided, whatever.
The realization there were
problems with pentagons goes
back a very, very long way.
Kepler knew that there were
problems, and no doubt the
ancient Greeks did, as well.
The ancient Greeks had
a lot of these
interesting tiling patterns.
Kepler made a real concerted
effort to get interesting
patterns using as small
a number of
different shapes as possible.
And he had something that
was pretty nice.
It contained a lot
of structure.
But it wasn't as good as what
Roger Penrose managed to come
up with in the 1970s, which was
a tiling using these, plus
three other shapes--
shapes appropriate for filling
in these gaps and rules again
to tell you when to put down a
pentagon and when to put in a
filling-in shape.
And he was able to come
up with a pattern
that went on forever.
It had a curious property that
it never repeated itself.
It kept on changing little
bits as you go along.
What Penrose had was he had a
systematic way of filling in
the gaps, and coming up with
a pattern where the local
configurations of all the
tilings kept on appearing
again and again-- just
in a different order.
So there were constant slight
changes, but the local patches
all looked more or less the
same as each other.
And this was the beginning of
the realization that there
were a lot of different patterns
that had this strange
property of non-repeating and
yet highly, highly structured.
How do we know patterns like
this never repeat themselves?
That really depends on the rules
that they're given by.
So each one of these has to
come with some kind of
description as to how
you make them.
One of the most common ways in
which patterns like this are
found are by taking a very
regular pattern, but in a much
higher dimensional space, and
then cutting through that
space at an irrational angle.
And the irrationality of the
way you've cut it will mean
that you'll never get
complete repetition.
Penrose tilings have been the
origin of a lot of excitement
for some time-- really
since the mid-1980s
when this story started.
Penrose discovered his tilings
in the '70s, and 10 years
later they were discovered to
be out there in nature.
And Dan Schlectman found that
he could make an alloy of
various different
types of metal.
And the atomic arrangements that
went into this alloy, the
way the atoms sat, arranged
themselves on a
three-dimensional version
of a Penrose Tiling.
It took quite a while for it to
be fully established, but I
guess it now really is
definitively established that
this is so as he got
the Nobel Prize for
Chemistry this last year.
BRADY HARAN: Why had people not
found it in nature before,
if there's a natural tendency
towards it?
JOHN HUNTON: Well, this is a
very interesting, perhaps
philosophic, question about
the nature of language.
Because one good answer--
I do believe this is
a good answer--
is we didn't see it, because
we didn't look for it.
I think the story to tell at
this point is the way in which
some years ago--
I think it was the 1930s--
material was found that, with
hindsight, we realized was
based on similar sort of
non-repeating patterns.
But we didn't have the
mathematics, the pure
mathematics--
the geometry had not
be discovered--
and we didn't have the language
to be able to either
talk about it or see it.
So I find it a great example of
how science can't see what
it doesn't have the language
to describe.